bonjour à tous c'est la fin des
questions au gouvernement on refait les
gags sur LCP on refait les questions au
Gouvernement très heureuse de vous
retrouver ici dans cette belle salle des
pas perdue à quelques mètres de
l'hémicycle ou viennent d'être s'achever
c'est question au gouvernement on va
revenir bien sûr sur les temps forts de
cette séance avec nos reporters salle
des quêtes colonnes elles a mon un Gabin
et Stéphanie Despierres ainsi qu'avec
Marco pommier qui se trouve cours
d'honneur c'est l'entrée principale du
palais Bourbon avec des ministres assez
cotés et puis avec nos invités aussi en
plateau on va débattre de tous ces
sujets aborder cet après-midi Carolina
Badi bonjour bienvenue vous êtes député
renaissance de l'Isère et Philippe
Balard bonjour député rassemblement
national de l'Oise
alors le compte-rendu de cette séance
avec Stéphanie Despierre qu'on retrouve
salle des quatre colonnes Stéphanie vous
avez quand même suivi cette séance
depuis les tribunes et vous ce que vous
retenez c'est un échange entre la
députée écologiste Sophie Tail et
polliant et le porte-parole du
gouvernement Olivier Veyron s'est à
propos de l'indépendance de la presse et
de la nomination de Geoffroy Lejeune à
la tête du JDD mais alors c'est plutôt
la question de cette députée écologiste
et les invectives qui jaillissaient du
côté du rassemblement national
sofitailler polliant c'est livré un long
plaidoyer pour l'indépendance des
journalistes elle a dit son soutien aux
journalistes du Journal du Dimanche qui
proteste contre l'arrivée de Geoffroy
Lejeune venue de valeur actuelle elle a
fustigé ceux qui ne soutiennent pas le
combat des journalistes ne sont pas des
républicains et c'est ça qui a déclenché
la colère du rassemblement national qui
eux défend l'arrivée de ce journaliste
les députés de Marine Le Pen criaient
garde tes leçons et la déontologie c'est
de la censure alors Sophie taillé
polluant la député écologiste
s'adressait à la ministre de la Culture
mais le porte-parole du gouvernement
Olivier Véran qui lui a répondu car la
ministre est à Marseille avec le
président de la République ce qui a
déclenché une nouvelle salle de cris sur
les bancs du rassemblement national oui
bien sûr très courageuse merci Stéphanie
Despierres pour ce compte rendu on va
bien sûr débattre de ce sujet sur
l'indépendance de la presse parce que
c'était le principal sujet qui a été
abordé cet après-midi mais nous sommes
en duplex avec Olivier du socle qui est
le ministre du Travail qui est aux côtés
de Marco pommier cours d'honneur alors
que dit-il face aux critiques sur ce
texte sur le partage de la valeur qui
est en discussion actuellement à
l'Assemblée et qui dit que bah ça va
empêcher les hausses de salaire
oui mais c'est justement la question
qu'on va poser à Olivier dussotte
bonjour monsieur le ministre la gauche
et le rassemblement national c'est vrai
sont plutôt sceptiques sur votre texte à
propos de la valeur dans les entreprises
sur le partage de la valeur dans les
entreprises vous vous dites qu'il faut
et bien passer par des primes par
l'intéressement eux et eux ils disent
bah il faut augmenter les salaires
est-ce que ça serait pas plus efficace
pour augmenter le pouvoir d'achat ce
n'est pas nous qui lisons sans les
organisations syndicales et les
organisations patronales le texte qu'on
nous examinons depuis lundi est un
projet de loi qui transpose un accord un
accord qui a été signé par les trois
organisations patronales le Medef la
CPME et l'u2p donc les grandes
entreprises les moyennes et les
tout-petites et ce texte est aussi été
signé par quatre des cinq organisations
syndicales en représentatives la CFDT
sans s'ouvrière la CFTC la CFE-CGC on
s'y est ce texte et les partenaires
sociaux cèdent sur 8 se sont mis
d'accord pour dire que en matière de
partage de la valeur évidemment qu'il y
a des questions de salaire et leur
accord ne règle pas cette question là
mais qu'il est important de pouvoir
faciliter la mise en place d'accord
d'intéressement et de participation des
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
qu'il est important faciliter la prime
de partage de la valeur et qu'il est
important lorsqu'une entreprise fait des
résultats exceptionnels qu'il y a un
intéressement exceptionnel ce sont trois
avancées majeures du texte que nous
proposons transposer et je pense que
nous aurons une majorité majorité
importante pour que ce texte tel qu'il a
été décidé par les partenaires sociaux
sont inscrits dans la loi vous pariez
une majorité importante justement mais
les socialistes on voit par exemple à
gauche pour évoquer votre texte même
s'il estime même s'il estime que c'est
insuffisant est-ce que vous ne comptez
pas faire un pas vers eux accepter
certaines de leurs propositions à
travers des amendements faire un pas
justement il y a déjà des amendements
qui ont été adoptés hier soir qui était
porté par la majorité présidentielle
mais qui répondent à des interrogations
des remarques d'autres groupes de
position le groupe socialiste par
exemple un système beaucoup sur le fait
de rappeler le principe de non
substitution c'est à dire de décrire
dans la loi que les primes ne remplacent
pas les salaires nous l'avons fait hier
soir cela a été inscrit et esclave vient
en plus du Code du travail qui est à son
article 33 12 pour être très précis dit
déjà qui ne peut pas y avoir de
substitution entre les primes salaires
ça fait partie des choses que nous
allons regarder de même qu'il y a
d'autres propositions je prends des
sociétés à me dégager des statues
particuliers sur lesquels nous pouvons
avancer je pense au domaine de
l'économie sociale et solide sont des
demandes de précision qui sont portées
par des députés de la majorité
présidentielle par des députés du groupe
socialiste par des députés du groupe LR
et vers lesquels nous allons nous allons
à une condition qui est très importante
à mes yeux c'est que au mois de
septembre dernier en 2022 avec la
première ministre nous avons dit au
partenaires sociaux que nous souhaitions
qu'il négocie et que s'il négocier nous
respecterions leur accord et donc à
chaque fois que nous donnons un avis
favorable à un amendement nous veillons
à ce que tous les signataires de
l'accord les quatre syndicats les trois
organisations patronales soient d'accord
avec certains moments autre dossier sur
votre bureau Olivier du soft le projet
de loi pour le plein emploi texte qui
doit donner naissance notamment à France
travail pour remplacer Pôle Emploi
qu'est-ce que ça va changer concrètement
ça va changer beaucoup de choses on
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
dans l'accompagnement des demandes
d'emploi et dans l'accompagnement aussi
des chefs d'entreprise qui recrutent
nous sommes dans une période très
particulière nous avons fait baisser le
chômage il est passé de 9,5 à 7,1% nous
avons des créations d'emplois nette qui
sont très importantes l'économie
française a créé presque un million
depuis 2017 malgré tout nous avons
encore 7% de chômage et les entreprises
peinent à recruter il y a le président
de la République l'a dit il a dit avec
ces mots mais c'est une réalité quand il
dit vous cherchez du travail mais
regardez autour faites le tour du vieux
port à Marseille il est au moins 10
offres d'emploi vos confrères les
journalistes de La Provence l'ont fait
ils en ont trouvé 13 y compris avec des
bars restaurants qui disent même si vous
n'avez pas de formation pas de
compétences particulières en vous
formant vous accueille tellement les
entreprises ont du mal à recruter et
donc nous allons investir dans
l'accompagnement faire en sorte que les
demandeurs d'emploi des allocataires du
RSA puisse avoir accès à plus de
formation plus de suivi ce n'est pas du
travail gratuit ça n'est pas du
bénévolat obligatoire mais vraiment aux
activités d'insertion et de formation
pour aller vers l'emploi merci beaucoup
Olivier du Sapt pour vos réponses merci
à vous merci Marco pommier retour donc
sur la principale information de cette
après-midi l'indépendance de la presse
la liberté des médias qui s'est invité
au cœur de l'hémicycle avec une question
du député démocrate des Yvelines Bruno
milliennes on va écouter la réponse que
lui a fait le porte-parole du
gouvernement Olivier Véran
la presse d'opinion elle est légale en
France et ce au nom du pluralisme des
médias et de la liberté de la presse qui
sont des principes fondamentaux dans
notre démocratie mais les inquiétudes
sont vives je le disais dans une partie
de la profession alors est-ce qu'il faut
aller plus loin que ce qui existe déjà
dans la loi comme les chartes
déontologiques les comités relatifs à
l'honnêteté à l'indépendance et au
pluralisme de l'information et des
programmes proposés de personnalités
indépendantes le droit actuel de
comporte par exemple aucune disposition
de nature à garantir l'indépendance des
rédactions à l'égard des tentatives
d'influence ou d'émissions de la part
d'actionnaires gouvernement souhaite
réfléchir à comment garantir renforcer
les garanties indispensables à notre
démocratie qui s'incarne aussi dans la
diversité des opinions toutes les pistes
sont donc ouvertes vous le savez
monsieur le député le président de la
République a d'ailleurs annoncé qu'il y
aura des états généraux de l'information
qui seront les bienvenus pour aborder
l'ensemble des problématiques l'ensemble
des problématiques n'ayez pas peur de se
les députés relatives à l'information
une valeur si cher dans notre pays
et nous accordons un droit de
responsable Bruno millienne député donc
démocrate des Yvelines qui a interpellé
Olivier Véran tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle ce qu'il est satisfait de la
réponse du porte-parole du gouvernement
le gouvernement vous répond faut-il
aller plus loin vous vous dites déjà
dans un premier temps ce qu'il faut
c'est condamner cette situation qui vous
choque on voit bien qu'il y a une dérive
moi que des que des gens très puissants
économiquement en face main basse sur
des organes de presse les phases vives
ça me pose aucun problème dès l'instant
il laisse entière liberté d'expression à
l'équipe rédactionnelle et qui imposent
pas leur vue politique ou économique la
liberté de presse c'est un droit
constitutionnel pour moi on ne doit pas
y toucher on constate une certaine
dérive depuis allez on va dire une
petite dizaine d'années progressive qui
s'est fait tranquillement où on voit que
des traits puissants mettent la main sur
des organes de presse alors au début ça
se passe bien puis après petit à petit
on impose ces vues ces vues idéologiques
et on transforme complètement finalement
les rédactions la ligne édit oriale que
ce soit des des journaux des journaux
papiers ou que ce soit des radios et et
des organes de télévision et ça ça me
pose un souci
ce qu'il faut selon vous que dans la loi
il y ait une séparation entre celui qui
possède les médias et la rédaction plus
de pouvoir peut-être pour ces rédactions
pour les journalistes dans un premier
temps il faudrait qu'on ait un garde-fou
quelque part qu'on trouve un garde-fou
mais ça ça nécessite un travail en
commun avec tout le monde et quand on
est d'accord parce que moi j'ai bien vu
quand j'ai posé ma question que sur la
partie droite de l'hémicycle j'étais un
peu chahuté comme si il était trouvé
normal que il y ait cette idéologie là
qui s'installe sans aucun problème mais
cette CE2 là elle peut exister et elle
existe déjà dans certains médias il y a
aucun problème c'est assumé par la
rédaction par la direction de la
rédaction ça me pose aucun problème là
où ça me pose problème c'est quand on
part sur une rédaction comme le Journal
du Dimanche qui est plutôt voilà on va
dire tout aubédience avec des gens qui
essayent de faire leur travail de la
manière la plus la plus objective
possible et à qui tout d'un coup on
impose par le choix d'un directeur de la
publication une ligne éditoriale qui ne
veulent pas et c'est ça qui me pose
souci et ça on l'a vu dans d'autres
médias on l'a vu à cnews on l'a vu à
Europe 1 pour ne pas les alors
évidemment il y a des auditeurs pour ça
il y a aucun problème mais il faut qu'on
arrive on arrive à trouver un équilibre
moi j'ai été journaliste quand même il y
a un moment où le droit d'information
c'est le droit d'informer des gens de
manière objective et pas seulement
orienté il en va un petit peu de notre
démocratie on a vu l'exemple aux
États-Unis avec Fox News qui a quand
même été une catastrophe il faut il faut
qu'on arrête ce genre de de dévoiement
je veux dire simplement qu'ils sont à la
seule de gens très puissant
financièrement et qui impose leur point
de vue à des rédactions merci beaucoup
Bruno mignonne on le rappelle vous avez
été effectivement ancien journaliste
alors j'ai un autre ancien journaliste
sur le plateau vous voyez le hasard fait
bien les choses Philippe Vallard merci
d'être là et puis surtout de pouvoir
répondre à cette question est-ce que
vous vous êtes d'accord avec ce que dit
Bruno Millien c'est-à-dire que il y aura
une information qui sera davantage
orientée avec ses grands groupes de
presse qui concentrent effectivement
tout dans leur main et notamment les
médias les plus importants et ce qu'il y
a une forme de dérive à laquelle on est
en train d'assister alors je vais
répondre à votre question vous en faites
pas je vois juste rectifier ce qui a été
dit tout à l'heure on ne favorise pas on
n'est pas pour l'arrivée de Geoffroy
Lejeune à la rédaction du JDD c'est une
entreprise privée indépendante enfin
voilà on n'a pas assimoncé
aujourd'hui par le Journal du dimanche
on n'a pas
on peut rebondir mais j'aurais pas
partir dans tous les sens par les hommes
Marine Le Pen du traitement réservé
rassemblement national par le Journal du
dimanche on a eu des conversations
directes on peut pas dire qu'on était
favorisés non nous on a posé une autre
question en l'occurrence Caroline
cliquez sur les propos les tweets
notamment de la ministre de la Culture
qui a twitté sur le JDD c'était
attention danger elle en était pas son
coup d'essai puisque il y a quelques
mois républicaines
mais là on se dirige tout doucement vers
une démocratie libère de ce rythme là il
y a quelques mois si on était pris assez
news en disant on va peut-être le
retirer leur émission leur autorisation
des maîtres et il y a le patron de
l'arôme monsieur rock Olivier Metz qui
avait dû faire un communiqué en disant
que c'était pas au ministère de la
Culture de désigner ceux qui allaient
avoir une licence et ceux qui n'allaient
pas avoir une licence
libérale c'est ce que vous dites
jusqu'au bout de la démarche et on
continue dans cette démarche ça fait ça
fait quand même réfléchir alors après il
y a équilibre il faut différencier quand
même l'audiovisuel de la presse écrite
déjà ils ne sont pas surveillés de la
même façon surveiller entre guillemets
il y en a qui sont régis par les par
l'art comme d'autres par des lois la
presse d'opinion papier enfin si vous
prenez l'humanité on connaît très bien
leur ligne politique libération connaît
très meilleur line politique va leurs
actuelles on connaît bien la ligne c'est
plutôt l'émission effectivement de
grands groupes industriels de chefs
d'entreprise sur le contenu même
éditorial ce qui porterait atteinte à
l'indépendance de la presse
l'indépendance des journalistes est-ce
que ça vous l'entendez il y a une
concentration effectivement un
démeublement on assiste à une
concentration
dans la presse écrite mais pas que
écrite après si on respecte la liberté
éditoriale aussi pour un titre de
presse-papier on donne une couleur
politique pourquoi pas voir audiovisuel
enfin je veux dire moi je l'ai dit en
commission les affaires culturelles ça a
été enregistré donc je peux vous redire
à votre antenne est-ce que c'est news
n'est pas pour la droite ce que France
Inter et pour la gauche voilà on
pourrait simplifier ça comme ça voilà
c'est une question c'est plus réaliste
c'est le pluralisme alors vous est-ce
qu'il y a atteinte au pluralisme coréen
Caroline Abadie ou pas dans dans cette
reprise en main de de on y voit la main
de Vincent Bolloré c'est un choix
d'Arnaud Lagardère qu'il défend il dit
que c'est un choix économique mais on
voit la bouche de 2016 quand les
salariés dit télé avaient fait 31 jours
de grève je pense que avant le rachat de
i-Télé on pouvait pas forcément dire que
donc l'ancien cnews que cette ligne
éditoriale était plus favorable à
donc mon voisin vient de le dire donc
voilà plus favorable à ses idées que
commiennes maintenant on peut le dire
donc c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un
changement malgré tout il y a les genoux
sont teintées effectivement
[Musique]
vous noterez que de nos pignons d'une
presse d'opinion mais on notera qu'elle
a changé après ce rachat donc
effectivement la loi Bloch de 2016 qui
avait mis des garde-fous et c'est on
peut s'en saluer on peut on peut le
saluer mais peut-être faut-il en
rajouter donc vous vous pensez qu'il
faut aller plus loin qu'il faut
légiférer c'est un sujet la teinte au
pluralisme je le vois pas parce qu'il y
a toujours une prise de gauche il y a
toujours un équilibre l'art comme de se
prononcer sur ce point là mais la
question c'est est-ce que petit à petit
l'indépendance des journalistes de
de n'aura pas petit à petit une
influence sur l'indépendance des
journalistes en fait ça le sujet c'est
petit à petit ça s'est pas fait du jour
au lendemain c'est indépendance elle est
menacée ou pas enfin vous vous avez été
journaliste vous savez ce que c'est que
l'indépendance de du de la presse on n'a
pas très envie qu'on vous qu'un
actionnaire vienne vous dicter tel
papier telle angle vous mettez concerné
dans les différentes rédactions que j'ai
traversé des rédactions
aujourd'hui au Journal du dimanche ou
pas nécessairement moi je sais pas j'ai
pas lu le journal du dimanche ou la
férule de Geoffroy Lejeune je pourrais
vous donner une réponse après mais
encore une fois si c'est un journal qui
devient un journal d'opinion avec une
certaine couleur politique on peut
peut-être deviner ça fera un journal
d'opinion de plus dans le paysage
français dont acte très bien de toute
façon la presse notamment papier s'ouvre
pour divers raisons parce que
l'électorat vieilli parce que le prix du
papier a explosé voilà on pourrait
multiplier les exemples parce que il y a
les réseaux sociaux il y a internet etc
etc donc un journal d'opinion de plus
mais on verra moi je fais pas procès
d'intention avant d'avoir lu le journal
intention non plus de votre côté
Carolina m'a dit pas de procès
d'attention par contre on a on peut
tirer les leçons de de ce qui s'était
passé chez iTélé pour se dire que il y a
peut-être des choses à faire donc ça
demande la pression des actionnaires je
voyais quelques propositions par-ci
par-là dans le ministre en a rappelé
notamment une chaleur éditoriale
éditoriale
de la rédaction transparence aussi sur
l'actionnariat de plus de 5%, je voyais
ça dans une proposition du Sénat en tout
cas c'est pas la première fois qu'on se
pose la question et comme ça revient
régulièrement on peut on peut
légitimement légiférer sur ce sujet je
pense allez on va passer à présent une
toute autre question qui a été abordée
cet après-midi c'est le hijab porté dans
les compétitions sportives c'est invité
à l'Assemblée nationale après la
décision du Conseil d'État de
l'autoriser c'est le président du groupe
les républicains Olivier Marleix qui a
interpellé la première ministre je vous
propose d'écouter la réponse d'Elisabeth
borne je veux avant toute chose
réaffirmer mon attachement et celui de
tout mon gouvernement au strict respect
du principe de laïcité je peux vous
assurer que je suis totalement mobilisé
avec la ministre des Sports Amélie ou
des à Castera pour le respect strict de
nos principes républicains dans le sport
en particulier la laïcité et la
neutralité du service public nous sommes
mobilisés pour garantir l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes notamment dans
le sport
nous sommes mobilisés pour lutter contre
toutes les formes de prosélytisme et de
radicalisation et avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin et la
ministre des Sports nous sommes en
première ligne pour combattre toutes les
formes de séparatisme dans les clubs
nous allons renforcer les contrôles à la
rentrée et nous n'hésiterons pas à
fermer des clubs qui promènent promovent
une idéologie radicale ou séparatiste
Philippe Ballard vous venez d'entendre
Elizabeth borne ça vous convient comme
réponse respect de la laïcité liée elle
s'y tiendra
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu là
ça a été deux minutes d'eau froide enfin
oui la pluie ça mouille et puis le feu
c'est chaud enfin des phrases mais
complètement creuses non il y a un
dangereux quand même à la rentrée
la question c'est pas celle-là c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe il conseille
d'État donc un juge pour l'instant c'est
un juge qui a fait émis un une
recommandation si les juges prennent le
pouvoir sur sur le politique là c'est
que se passe-t-il si on autorise des
joueuses de football apporter le hijab
voilà les questions simples est-ce qu'il
faut une projet de loi une proposition
de loi pour contrer ça on n'a pas eu de
réponse on a eu oui c'est pas bien oui
la laïcité on est tous pour un là il y a
pas de problème les dérives faut les
condamner oui mais tout le monde est
d'accord tout le monde est d'accord sauf
qu'on a pas là on a pas la réponse enfin
il y a un phénomène qui gangrène la
société française c'est le
communautarisme et on faisait marqué
dans l'hémicycle l'équipe d'Algérie
féminin ne portait pas de hijab l'équipe
marocaine ne portait pas de hijab
tunisienne ne portait pas de hijab et la
Sénégalaise ne portait pas des hutabs
donc on va très bien ce qui se passe en
France il y a des footballeuses qui se
servent de ce symbole pour ses coups de
butoir aux
entreprises
qui se développe c'est les repas halal
c'est le burkini voilà et ça s'inscrit
maintenant le hijab quand on joue au
football donc il faut réagir mais réagir
très très vite alors on rappelle la
règle actuellement en vigueur
c'est-à-dire la Fédération Française de
Football interdit le hijab dans les
compétitions sportives alors que la
Fédération internationale elle
l'autorise est-ce que la décision du
Conseil d'État va obliger la Fédération
Française de Football a autorisé le
hijab dans les compétitions c'est parce
que semble dire Elizabeth borne mais en
même temps il y a une décision du
Conseil d'État Isabelle borne elle a
déjà rappelé qu'elle pouvait pas
commenter une décision qui n'était pas
encore rendue je pense que la séparation
des pouvoirs nous nous impose d'attendre
un petit peu avant de se s'enflammer sur
ce qu'on fait facile le Conseil d'État
se prononce pour et en l'occurrence si
c'est contre peut-être qu'on
s'enflammera moins effectivement mais on
a quand même beaucoup agi nous depuis
2017 mais particulièrement sur la loi
sur le séparatisme et on l'a bien
rappelé ses principes là de neutralité
du service public de de nombreux
élitisme dans des clubs qui sont
financés par de l'argent public tout ça
on l'a déjà réaffirmé et la première
mise sera plus le redire tout à l'heure
il y a eu 3500 contrôles l'année
dernière qui ont amené à 23 fermetures
donc ce ne sont pas que des paroles ce
ne sont pas que des réponses c'est des
actions qui ont vraiment eu lieu l'année
dernière et on est on est très ferme là
dessus mais voyez que on aurait
quelqu'un d'autre sur le plateau on
aurait on aurait on serait on serait
nous aussi parce que on est trop ferme
si toutefois ce serait c'était autorisé
en France est-ce que vous vous seriez
favorable à ce qui est une loi est-ce
que vous pourriez la voter puisqu'on a
entendu Olivier Marleix qui voulait
déposer un texte
moi je préfère réfléchir avant de partir
sur tout de suite une loi voir
constitutionnellement ce qu'on peut
faire sur ces sujets là le fait que pour
moi un terrain de foot n'est pas un lieu
pour véhiculer une idéologie ni
politique ni religieuse et que ça me
gênerait personnellement mais avec faut
voir dans quel c'est bien une
revendication politique pour vous oui et
vous Philippe Balard vous vous enfin
vous ajouteriez aux voix des des
républicains pour voter un texte
Marine Le Pen a dit qu'elle souhaitait
aussi légiférer là-dessus de mémoire une
proposition de loi qui allait en ce sens
est-ce qu'on vous voterait une
proposition de loi de LR en fait comme
ils ont plutôt tendance à nous copier
depuis des mois c'est peut-être eux qui
voteront notre proposition de loi ça
serait quand même un petit peu plus
logique parce que là depuis les propos
des trois responsables des républicains
donc JDD tiens justement dont on parlait
tout à l'heure on voit que c'est du
mauvais copier-coller qu'ils font du
programme de Marine Le Pen et de celui
du rassemblement national on va parler à
présent d'une de la mort d'un jeune
homme de 17 ans j'étais ce matin à
Nanterre suite à un contrôle de police a
suscité beaucoup de réactions notamment
de la gauche et une question de la
députée écologiste des Hauts-de-Seine on
va écouter la réponse de Gérald Darmanin
ce matin en effet à Nanterre deux
motards de la DOPC de la préfecture de
police ont procédé un contrôle nous ne
connaissons pas sauf les images
extrêmement choquantes que j'ai vu
personnellement comme beaucoup de
Français les conditions exactes puisque
les policiers en ce moment sont
auditionnés par les services de la
justice deux enquêtes ont été confiées à
l'IGPN et évidemment je veux aussi dire
que c'est un drame que ce jeune
conducteur de 17 ans soit mort des
suites de ce contrôle manifestement je
veux aussi vous dire ici que je suis
très attaché à la protection de
l'innocence des accusés et notamment de
celui qui a attiré qui est policier qui
aura rencontré devant son administration
et devant la justice de ses actes mais
je ne suis pas juge je ne suis pas
procureur de la République madame et je
veux aussi être attentif à la
présomption des fonctionnaires de 197
fonctionnaires de police
Sabrina c'est Bailly qui a interpellé
Gérald Darmanin député écologiste des
Hauts-de-Seine est au micro de Stéphanie
Despierre bonjour qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la réponse que vous a fait le
ministre
alors une réponse plutôt claire et posée
même si je suis pas en totale accord
avec tout ce qui a été dit moi je pense
qu'il y a un vrai un vrai problème
aujourd'hui avec la doctrine sur le
refus d'obtempérer on a eu 13 morts en
2022 donc ça veut bien dire que ça ne
fonctionne pas qu'il y a un
dysfonctionnement dans cette doctrine et
c'est là où nous sommes dans des accords
et puis surtout moi je ne suis pas là
pour opposer les morts les unes aux
autres une mort c'est déjà une mort de
trop vous avez évoqué dans votre
question et vous l'évoquez là la loi de
2017 alors Gérald Darmanin dit que la
loi qui a retouché un peu l'usage des
armes à feu par les policiers que depuis
2017 il y a moins de tirs et moins de
cas mortels ce n'est pas votre avis
comme je le disais à partir du moment où
on a des chiffres aussi accablants que
ce qu'il y a en 2022 c'est-à-dire
vraiment 13 morts en 2022 et puis là on
est on n'a pas encore fini l'année 2023
et on assiste déjà à plusieurs décès
donc on voit bien que ce dispositif tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui en tout cas exercé
ne fonctionne pas s'ils fonctionnait
correctement il n'y aurait pas de mort
en réalité sur les reflux d'obtempérer
donc on voit bien qu'il y a un
dysfonctionnement quelque part et puis
la vidéo aujourd'hui qui a circulé
énormément toute la journée sur ce refus
d'obtempérer en tout cas sur ce qui
semble être un refus d'obtempérer est
assez en réalité elle montre vraiment la
difficulté et le drame de ce qu'on a
vécu ce matin à Nanterre Gérald Darmanin
a aussi souligné que souvent les
victimes des refus d'obtempérer sont les
gendarmes qui parfois meurent en service
oui mais c'est ce que je vraiment c'est
ce que je disais moi je n'oppose pas du
tout les morts les unes aux autres j'ai
d'ailleurs commencé ma question par
rappeler le travail difficile des
policiers aujourd'hui mais c'est
justement parce que le cadre légal
aujourd'hui n'est pas adapté que nous
mettons nos policiers en difficulté et
en danger et que par ailleurs nous
assistons à ce à quoi on assiste
aujourd'hui à savoir des morts de jeunes
de 17 ans
Caroline Abadie vous avez entendu
Sabrina sebahi elle dit que le cadre
n'est pas adapté aujourd'hui elle pointe
des dysfonctionnements dans cette
doctrine de de du refus d'obtempérer ce
qu'il faut revoir les règles modifier
les choses
je suis aussi ému un quel quand on
apprend le décès de quelqu'un qui a
refusé d'obtempérer et qui
malheureusement finissent ces jours
beaucoup plus tôt que ce qu'il aurait dû
à 17 ans je peux imaginer la souffrance
et la peine de la famille
elle ne veut pas opposer les morts mais
elle oublie de chiffrer ce qui sont
victimes tous les jours du refus
d'obtempérer il meurt pas à chaque fois
mais j'ai donc les morts du côté de la
police du côté de la police des
commandants un commandant à Vienne il y
a quelques semaines a été renversé il en
est pour sa dixième opération il en aura
peut-être encore des dizaines et des
dizaines il a survécu mais on peut aussi
témoigner son émotion dans ces cas là
moi je pense que il faut quand même
réaffirmer que c'est quand même la
police qui détient le droit de faire de
la force et quand elle demande de la
violence légitime voilà c'est c'est en
étant dans un état de droit il faut
quand même un moment aussi rappeler les
fondamentaux quand il y a un barrage de
police on s'arrête point barre je veux
bien voir le cadre pour voir si on peut
éviter des mises en danger de nos forces
de l'ordre et des contenants mais je
pense qu'il faut aussi rappeler ses
principes basiques Philippe Balard
est-ce qu'il y a un
usage disproportionné de la force sur
ses refus d'obtempérer non mais émotion
et respect pour les victimes et respect
aussi de la présomption d'innocence
parce que moi ce qui m'a dérangé tout à
l'heure dans la question de ma collègue
de notre collègue c'est quand même que
on avait le sentiment qu'elle avait fait
l'instruction et qu'on était déjà dans
le temps du procès on va attendre il y a
une enquête en cours on sait pas ce qui
s'est passé avant on a un peu de mal à
comprendre ce qui se passe sur le sur le
moment à l'instant T donc l'enquête est
en cours on n'a pas aller plus loin faut
juste se rappeler quelques chiffres
puisqu'elle aura plait il y a plus de
10000 policiers gendarmes qui sont
blessés en service tous les ans il y en
a selon les entre 12 et 25 qui meurent
en service et il y a un refus
d'obtempérer toutes les 20 minutes voilà
il faut avoir présent ça à l'esprit
policier ne tue pas parce que moi j'ai
vu des tweets de nos collègues
circulaient déjà non la police ne tue
pas
cet après-midi c'est en l'occurrence
c'est pas lui la police nous protège et
quand un policier ou un gendarme faute
bah il est poursuivi il est condamné et
il est exclu il y a plus de 100
policiers qui ont été exclus de la
police l'an passé il y a des enquêtes
qui sont en cours et en vrai évidemment
toute la lumière sur sur cette affaire
enquête comme ça à Nanterre et de l'IGPN
pour voir s'il y a eu photo ou pas merci
en tout cas à tous les deux d'être venu
débattre sur ce plateau merci à
Stéphanie Despierres Elsa monanga va et
Marco pommier qui m'ont accompagné tout
au long de cette émission merci à vous
tous de nous regarder chaque semaine et
on se retrouve mardi prochain pour une
nouvelle séance de questions au
Gouvernement sur LCP